[Music]
equipped with an hourglass to remind us
that death will come to all
and wielding a scythe to harvest
unfortunate souls
he reaps what has been sown hence the
name
the grim reaper nowadays the grim
reapers become a pop culture icon
recognized across the world in books
comics tv shows movies and games
as a quintessential symbol of death and
whilst we're so familiar with who the
grim reaper is and what he does
we are less certain about his origins
where does a grim reaper come from
the answer may surprise you
so many world myths and cultures have
some sort of personification of death
especially in the form of a god or
goddess the greeks had thanatos
literally translating to death he is
sometimes depicted as a beautiful winged
man
occasionally cloaked in black and
carrying a sword but in later depictions
thanatos appears as a little winged boy
similar to cupid
this time who carries an upside-down
torch eerily representing a life
extinguished
the aztecs have miktek wattle the queen
of the realm of the dead
who rules the afterlife with mikhlang
takutly her husband
hindu and buddhist mythologies have king
yama who rides top of buffalo holding a
lasso
to drag souls into the afterlife as
buddhism spread to the far east
so too did he in china king yama turned
it to king yan
and in japan as king enma but another
common symbol for death
other than a god is a spectral figure
who escorts a living into the world to
the dead
look at these ancient north american
cave paintings they feature these
otherworldly beings who are believed to
represent spirits that accompany souls
into the afterlife
and you may have heard of caron in greek
myth a hooded figure who ferries are
recently deceased over the river styx
in their passage to the underworld all
for free of course
and in korean myth there is the
netherworld emissary the jolson saga
he's depicted as a strict bureaucrat
attempting to meet his busy quota of
souls for the day
now these personifications of death are
along the right lines for the grim
reaper
a figure that appears at the moment of
death to take you away with him
so where does he come from well it's not
really the bible
at least not as a cloak skeleton
wielding a scythe the angel of death
sometimes known as azrael is often seen
as the strongest candidate
but the bible doesn't really offer any
physical description of the angel
no skulls and sides in sight an angel of
death's job is to kill people
the grim reaper doesn't really do the
killing here perhaps the grim reaper is
one of the four horsemen of the
apocalypse mentioned in the book of
revelations
after all death the final horseman of
the apocalypse
is the only one that's actually named
but again there's no physical
description offered for a grim reaper
in greek the language of the original
script the horseman is actually named
thanatos
death the same name for the deity of
death in the myth of ancient greece
and arguably a closer inspiration for
this biblical character
so instead of the bible there may be
good reason to believe that the grim
reaper comes from a series of folklores
across
europe in the netherlands there exists
the mega hein
also known as the bender man bone man
similar to the grim reaper and looks
the mega hein is a skeletal figure who
appears at times of death and pestilence
but perhaps the closest parallel comes
from celtic folklore in a being known as
the anku
an anku appears as a man or a skeleton
and it wears a cloak
and often wields a scythe and in some
stories it's described as a shadow
often the top of a cart collecting the
dead he's even said to wear a black robe
with a large hat which conceals his face
he's one of death's henchmen
and his job ranges from protecting
graveyards to collecting souls on death
behalf
and according to a later christian
legend the anku was the first child of
adam and eve
from these figures the modern grim
reaper first emerged
it coincided with and was likely caused
by a key event in the mid 14th century
around 1346 a mysterious disease had
arrived to europe from asia
and people were becoming infected by the
millions now known as the black death
it became one of the worst pandemics
that has ever existed
to your average medieval peasant it
would seem that the end times were close
the foul stench of rotting flesh was
everywhere dead bodies lined the streets
were loaded into cards and dumped into
plague pits
during its peak years of 1346-1353
the total number of deaths in europe
could be anywhere between 45 to 60
percent
more than half of europe dead within a
few years and it wasn't just europe the
black death may have reduced the global
population from an estimated 475 million
to 350 million just over a quarter of
earth's human population
death was everywhere and the motif of
skeletons disease and mortality became
extremely prevalent in art and
literature
an idea known as the dance of death or
dance macabre
quickly emerged death became a
personified and ever-present figure who
did not discriminate between good or bad
rich or poor holy or unholy kings and
peasants were the same
and will just as likely join death's
gruesome dance
all this likely combined with those
pre-existing figures of folklore such as
omega hein or the anku
and all were homogenized into one single
skeletal figure
the grim reaper and since then the grim
reaper made its way into the hearts
minds and nightmares of everyday folk so
real or not is ultimately up to you
but in the case of the grim reaper let's
hope to never find that one out
ourselves
hey thanks for watching so as usual
links are in the description down below
so the channel is currently in an
ongoing spike in activity in subscribers
so welcome if you're new here and if you
enjoy my content and want to see more
like comment but most of all subscribe
to the channel
i look forward to seeing you next time
[Music]
goodbye
you